you got uh in the business with uh
Eminem right he did he discover you or
something yeah Eminem he had um got his
hands on a copy of a mixtape that I put
out through my attorney's deals that of
my uh Paul rosenberger's Eminem's
representation and he they have a
relationship so that's how you got the
CD but you grew up poor and everything
right not poor but not rich yeah like
where'd you grow up I grew up in South
Jamaica oh South Jamaica yeah Queen
Queen's not the country
so how do you get this tape into the
right hands like how do you become this
big star I mean oh man I'm really
blessed you know I'm a lucky person who
who found this tape I mean to send it to
Eminem I mean he had a lawyer well how
did you get a lawyer my attorney like I
had already originally I was signing Jam
Master Jay right jmj and from Jay's
torrent schedule Run DMC I became so
hectic that he wasn't able to focus on
me right so I moved on without him and I
was blessed with the opportunity of
working with Corey Rooney he was an
executive at Columbia at the time so I
ended up signing a track masters and
you're a tough guy I mean you've been
shot how many times nine times yeah nine
times and you lived yeah it was one
incident though it wasn't nine times
once yeah and you were shot in the face
too yeah it's a little Deadpool I don't
even see you how long was this yeah a
nine millimeter you can see the oh yeah
look at that oh yeah yeah look at that
okay knocked it imagine getting shot in
the head in living wow you're very
blessed his mouth you got shot in the
mouth but still you know your head and
you said it was funny yeah I mean well
you know what after you go through
situations when you're not in control of
them right you know it it doesn't like
people go wow like this guy's been shot
yeah does it hurt yeah it hurts but
knowing times I mean this was a bad shot
yeah this was a guy hit you in all the
wrong places yeah it was just a lot of
Flesh Wounds a lot of Flesh Wounds like
he was out to kill you though not to
scare you yeah and he hit you nine times
and yet he was unable to kill you not to
kill shot when your time comes you're
gonna go but wait a minute let me ask
you how this is going on is the guy
driving by Are you standing uh what's
going on let us in on the fun I can't
even sat down into the car and the guy
came from out of another vehicle and ran
up on the other car like a sneak attack
yeah and then like the person was
driving the car that I was in was like
scared like they got so scared that they
didn't pull off so right well they just
sat there and let you get shot yeah they
was hesitant because it was like a shot
now you say the guy who shot you is dead
now right yeah he's dead how did he die
same thing somebody shot him yeah he's
he's 27 years old you've already done
all this well you're like Superman
you've been shot nine times you haven't
been killed I mean yeah
right you've been stabbed twice how does
that feel but you know my baby mama like
I got an altercation in the Hit Factory
in the studio we was in the studio got a
little incident but it was only like
three stitches they said I got stabbed I
felt like that was a promotional stunt
oh but you know
you see I feel like you're under a lot
of pressure not not to be it's hard
enough to be a recording artist and come
out with hit songs but I feel like you
you got all this pressure with people
after you stabbing you bodyguard it
sounds a lot worse than the actual
situation you know I'm worried about you
you seem like a nice guy you know what
it is it's like
when like
trouble kind of like finds me
because you know it it really comes from
me just saying exactly how I feel yeah
yeah you know just like with your
parents and all this my mom's passed
away she got killed when I was like
eight years old man and I never knew my
father so I grew up with my grandparents
how'd your mother where was your father
would he run off uh yeah I never knew
him he wasn't around at all he's not
trying to find you now that you're uh he
has not come there man I'm sorry to hear
that that's that's a tough life yeah
it's all good you know when you go when
you're going through a situation that
you have no control of it's kind of easy
not to have your mother or father man
that's tough yeah but well from
everybody if you got both parents you
spoil you
you know what I mean